man there is nothing like having old
people marriage problems to get my
button the seat
nothing Hope Springs stars Meryl Streep
Tommy Lee Jones and Steve Carell it's
about this older couple and Meryl Streep
is just she's tired of her marriage
they've been married for like 31 years
they don't have sex anymore they don't
do anything together they barely even
talk anymore they barely even look at
each other there at the dinner table and
they eat dinner they go to work they do
the routine but they're not really happy
and so she decides to look into this
marriage counseling thing with a lot of
reluctance from Tommy Lee Jones they end
up going to this resort town in Maine to
talk with Steve Carell who's a marriage
counselor and they try to work out their
problems and hopefully try to find a way
to enhance their marriage again okay
normal I'm so glad you're here you to
have come here to try to restore
intimacy to your marriage this is insane
we're not 22 years old anymore
I would like to assign you your first
exercise tonight I would like you to
spend a period of time with your arms
around one another now when you think
about that plot a person my age the
demographic that I am I'm in my 20s this
isn't exactly something I'm going to
easily people to relate to or possibly
even enjoy but I found myself really
enjoying this movie for a lot of
different reasons I was actually shocked
at how much fun I had with this movie
for one there are actors in this movie
who are playing characters so out of
their comfort zone Tommy Lee Jones is so
vulnerable in this movie he's this timid
character you know he's a husband who is
really uncomfortable about speaking
about anything romantic with his wife in
front of anyone
he's even uncomfortable with the idea of
having romantic anything with his wife
anymore they've grown so apart so to see
him suddenly thrust into these
situations in which he's forced to
discuss rather revealing and
embarrassing details of his former sex
life basically it's so much fun to watch
him squirm in his seat and he's like nah
boy I don't want talk about that now
that's too much for me that was like
Morgan Freeman I don't know I tried it's
so neat to see him in a role like that
because he's normally an actor who's so
on top of things all the time
to see him demoted really to such an
embarrassing level is so pleasurable to
watch also Steve Carell in this movie
plays a completely straight-laced
character who rarely pops a joke at all
I was so surprised at just how
straightforward his character was and he
really held
his own amongst these veteran actors in
these scenes and he was really the one
who was just ratcheting on the tension
with these questions this tell me more
about this tell me more about this and
you could just see everyone just kind of
going like I'm looking for sex for
straight women from gay man it's most
likely way out of your comfort zone
I'm just not that's not me I just can't
do that at this point it's kind of
become a cliche to say that Meryl Streep
was great in this movie because she's
always good but she is of course
excellent in this movie she brings such
a luminous quality to her character you
know she's one of the actors who's so
real it just seems like she's just
slipping on a coat or a shoe or
something just it's so easy for her to
inhabit the character and she never
comes off as showy in this movie where
in the past I've always kind of thought
that maybe she's ate up the scenery a
little bit too much she's very very good
in this movie and she brings such a nice
quality to her character but honestly
the thing I liked so much about this
movie was the fact that in movies
nowadays and really honestly think about
this in movies nowadays when a comedy is
meant to be generally more awkward or
embarrassing and that's how it gets a
lot of its humor a lot of times the
scene will end right when the most
embarrassing moment happened and
everyone's just like oh oh and then it
just ends and you're on to the next
scene you never get to see how the
characters then get out of that moment
how what happens next you know that's
what is really the meat of the funny
thing that just happened this movie
doesn't cut away from those situations
like there were so many times in this
movie when I was almost positive that
okay this scene is gonna end now and
we're gonna hear about how they talk
that over later but no it doesn't they
continue to talk about whatever it is
that all of a sudden just got everyone
going like I don't know if I want to
mention that this team doesn't end and
for that reason we as the audience get
more pleasure watching these people just
like sink into their seats which isn't
so will we won't be together
okay next step what is the brighter
point hold hands in public saying
serenade is sex but not only is this
movie a lot of fun I really started
caring for these characters I honestly
wanted to see them okay and that is the
true sign of a good movie when you care
enough about these characters that you
start to view them as people and you
just want to see them in some kind of
good place you want to know what the
next thing they're gonna say is you want
to see how they're gonna get out of this
situation if senior citizens sex issue
comedies aren't exactly your cup of tea
I understand that because it's not mine
either
but you might actually find yourself
pleasantly surprised with this movie I'm
gonna give Hope Springs a B+ so if you
guys do see the movie let me know what
you think about it below I'm interested
in hearing your opinion and as always
thanks for watching guys and if you
liked this review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuck mind